OPENING FACE-OFF FORO WRONG-FOOT
KOSKINEN THERE BUT HE FLICKED IT
22nd ON THE YEAR AND YOU WELL AN
TRANSITION THE
AND A SURPRISE, I WOULD SAY,
LOUIE, JUST SIX POINTS IN BEHIN,
BLOCKED IN GOING
UP TO CLEAR COUSINS.
KOSKINEN, HE HAD TROUBLE
REGA SAROS, TRYING TO
GET A PIECE THAT LITTLE
TASTE, LIKED IT A LOT.
IN
BEHIND KEITH, KEITH, GAMBLED,
EARLIER IN HIS CAREER.WN FOR
>> Jack: THIS IS KEITH, WINDING
IT UP, PUTTING ONE-TIMER AND THT
STICK, SNAPPED ON A BLOCKED SHOS
AND TIME TO GO IN THIS ONE, BUT
PROBLEM. GOES OFF OF
TWO-ON-ONE, EDMONTON, IF THEY
HURRY BUT IT IS KASSIAN, BELEL N
KOSKINEN AND JEANNOT, ANOTHER
FROM HIS ROOKIE
BOUCHARD, INCLUDING THAT GOAL
THAT TIED IT AT TWOS AND THEN, ,
DOWN LOW AND THIS
CARRIER AND THEN SHOOK OFF THAT
POTE GAME.
THE CHANCE HERE TO RELOAD.
>> Louie: AN EXCELLENT SAVE BYWD
EDMONTON WITH THE OPTION HERE TO
CHANGE AS LEON SEEKING
VICTORY, AND IT IS NURSE,AVID.
HE STAYS WITH IT, LONG ENOUGH
FOR EKHOLM TO COMETONIGHT.HERE .
SECOND IN THE LEAGUE
OPEN UP THOSE SHOOTING OPTIONS
>> Jack: AND FORSBERG, 31% FOR
HIS CAREER, IN ON KOSKINEN WITH
.
SAROS?
GLOVE UP, THINKING THAT THAT WAS
GOING
>> Louie: HE WILL SEE KOSKINEN
IN HIS SLEEP HER THE SCORPION, G
THAT PAD UP JUST T